اقبال الواسع لمنتجات تمور يشهدو مهرجان
تسويق تمور الاحسان المصنعه بنسخه الجديده
والتمور في الاحساس تعتبر من اكثر واهم
الثروات التي تتميز بها المنطقه لا طول
تاريخها الممتاز لاعلاف السنين ومن امبرز
الحلوى الحساويه المصنوعه من التمر
والمعروضه في المهرجان ياتي سفسيف الحساوي
الذي يعد من اهم الاطباق الشعبيه الشتويه
في محافظه الاحساء ام ابراهيم احد السيدات
التي بدانا في من الصفر في عالم السمور
فبعد ان كان تصنع سيف في منزلها اصبح
لديها قاعده كبيره من الزبائن وافتتحت
متجر الخاص نتعرف عليها في قصه من الشارع
مع عبد الرحمن العصيمي
[موسيقى]
ينورنا وراسي صباح العربيه عبد الرحمن
العصيمي الحديث عن اشهر التمور اهلا بك يا
عبد الرحمن يسعد صباحك
هلا والله صباح الخير سهام صباح الخير
نادين يا اهلا وسهلا فيكم
وحياكم الله من الحسا الحسا عساك لو الدهر
نساك اليوم احنا من معرض تمور في الاحساء
هذا المعرض اللي بدا تقريبا قبل اسبوع
يمتد لمده
اكثر من شهر تقريبا هذه السنه ياتي بنسخه
مختلفه ومشاركه كبيره من تجار ومزارع تمور
في الاحساء طبعا انا قبل اسبوع ناديه سهام
كنت هنا في المعرض وكنت على الهواء مباشره
لنشرها الرابعه مع الزملاء
وشد انتباهي محل ام ابراهيم ولما سالت عنه
طبعا كان في زحمه واقبال عليه كبير خاصه
في المساء ام ابراهيم قصه حقيقيه ملهمه
للغايه هي بدات من منزلها بعمل صناعه
السفسيف ثم اصبح لديها محل معروف واصبحت
في المعارض بطريقه احترافيه جدا طبعا
اليوم نورتنا ام ابراهيم صباح الخير ام
ابراهيم اول شيء ام ابراهيم انت كيف جاتك
فكره السفسيف كيف بدات هذه هذه الصناعه
الجميله الحساويه العريقه والاصيله اولا
يسعد صباحكم يسعد صباح المشاهدين اشكرك
قناه العربيه على هذه الاستضافه اشكر سيدي
صاحب السمو الملكي الامير سعود بن نايف لن
نتشرف بزياره ركن المتواضع ثلاث مرات
تقريبا على مدى صحيحه فهذا اعتبر الدعم لي
واللي مشروع المتواضعتيني من بيتك صحيح
انا بديت مشروعي صغير بدايتها من الصفر
نقدر نقول في البيت كنت اعد السيف بكميات
قليله نعطيها هدايا للاصدقاء للاقارب همم
حدث لنا صور صور عبد الرحمن يعني فقط لغير
السعوديين لمن لا يعرف ما هو تفسير فقط
يعني اشرح لنا ما هو تفسير مما يتكون
بالضبط نيوزلان مبلش بس بالاول خلينا نشرح
اول شيء السفسيف بعدين نتكلم عن الموضوع
البدايه طيب خلينا نشرح للمشاهدين خاصه
فيك كثير مشاهدين عرب يمكن ما يعرف ايش هو
تفسير ايش مكونات السفير هو عباره عن تمر
زيت يكون منظف تمر اسماء رزازه وهو من
اشهر انواع التمور في الاحساء تقريبا من
بعد الاخلاص طيب شو رايك نسوي الحين كده
بشكل سريع طيب الان قلنا السفف
بعدين نحط عليه الخطوه الاولى هو اضافه
الدبس التمر
واو يعني هذا دبس تمر اخلاص
يوضع على نوع من التمور اسمه رزيز طبعا كل
التمر هذه من الحسد كله من مصادر الحساسه
صحيح بعد ما حطينا الدبس نبدا نحرك
احيانا يختارون الدبس ما يكون خلاص
على حسب الرغبه يعني في حريه يعني خلاص
اوكي يعني التمر
الدبس شفتي
لازم يتغلغل الدبس الى كافه
تمر تاخذ حقها من الدرس تعطيها لمعه وعلى
اساس لما انا اضيف السمسم والحلوه الحلوه
ام ابراهيم
طيب ومعنى ايضا مكون ثالث
حراره ودفع بالشتاء اوكي
بس عندنا العصيده
كانوا اهلنا يعتبرونها كوجبه فطور
واذا المراه في النفاس كانت تعد لها كوجبه
فطور غنيه بالفيتامينات والمعادن مكوناتها
اشتري يعني ام ابراهيم
الله طبعا انا هذوقها الان صيام نديم يعني
عبد الرحمن كان هذا فطور المفضل في
السعوديه العصيده والحساويه
مش فاضي لك عبد الرحمن
وفيها تعطيك طاقه على الصباح طبعا
تعطيك يعني حتى الدفى بالشتاء من الاكلات
اللي تدفي الانسان وتقييم من برد الشتاء
القارس عبد الرحمن السعوديه